c'est un petit pays que le reste du
monde a oublié
sa devise pourrait peut-être pour vivre
heureux vivons cachés ceux qui
découvrent le bouton souvent tourné
autour dans l'himalaya
d'où un royaume qui déploie beaucoup
d'énergie à protéger ses traditions
elles sont intactes depuis des siècles
nous allons suivre un guide français
robert dompnier et le groupe qui
l'accompagnent
je suis immédiatement tombé sous le
charme d'un pays qui avait su garder ou
si bien son identité qui avait su
préserver tellement bien sa culture sa
tradition sa religion un peuple dont la
cause nationale est la recherche du
bonheur et ça ça vous transforme un
voyage en quête initiatique
[Musique]
ici on peut découvrir ou redécouvrir
effectivement un certain état d'esprit
certaines approches du bonheur
quand on dit qu'il faut aller au bout du
monde pour se trouver c'est peut-être du
bhoutan dont on parle
[Musique]
c'est sur une route de montagne dans le
centre du pays que nous faisons
connaissance avec le groupe des français
ils ont le rire facile hein sans doute
la fatigue
depuis trois jours qu'ils sont ici ils
n'ont pas beaucoup dormi
parmi eux quelques cadres mais surtout
des retraités
claude était dentiste pour lui comme
pour les autres deux semaines deux
boutons c'est un investissement
combien vous avez payé pour ça
mais
un pays cher que l'on visite forcément
en voyage organisé
le bouton une démocratie mais il ne
s'ouvre que très progressivement ils
n'accueillent que vingt mille touristes
par an pour arriver à la frontière
bonjour toc toc bonjour monsieur le
douanier voilà j'arrive au bhoutan et je
vais me promener pas possible le
tourisme est encadré vous arrivez
effectivement vous avez donc compris
dans votre forfait une voiture ou un bus
selon taille du groupe un chauffeur et
un guide
bref sentiers battus obligatoires
le groupe est arrivé à l'hôtel ambiance
champêtre un peu frisquette
le guide bhoutanais à réserver l'hôtel
al avance il n'y en a pas beaucoup dans
le pays la seule initiative que vont
prendre nos français c'est de se
répartir le clae rôle qui incombe à
claude
inspection des chambres avec claude et
monique
c'est un standard occidental qui leur
convient même s'ils refont l'aménagement
ces savoyards ne sont pas compliquées
voici claudine une baroudeuse
on imagine mieux posant son sac à dos
dans un refuge que dans un hôtel coquet
comme celui ci
pour
joly c'est toi c'est chambre coûte
normalement 25 euros
mais au bhoutan tous les touristes
doivent payer 170 euros de forfait
journalier
pour en savoir plus direction timtoo la
capitale
c'est le gouvernement qui fixe le
forfait il prend au passage 35 % de
commission on comprend mieux le prix du
voyage
pourquoi cette politique
voici lagence qui s'occupe de nos
français
bienvenue dans mon agent
sonam la patronne affiche un air heureux
qui sied si bien à son pays
voici tenzin et voici karma qui prépare
tous les voyages organisés
cette femme d'affaires le dis
franchement
le forfait sert à faire barrage aux
routards
ils sont vus comme une menace pour les
traditions bhoutanaise et lui c'est mon
mari il s'est installé à mon ordinateur
[Musique]
notre idée c'est d'attirer des touristes
très haut de gamme
un petit nombre mais très haut de gamme
n'est-ce pas dommage que les jeunes et
les routeurs ne puisse pas venir au
bhoutan
en fait le bouton n'est pas le genre de
pays où les jeunes et des routards ont
envie de venir
d'abord nous n'avons pas tellement de
loisirs pour eux
et puis nous sommes très stricts en
matière de drogue
mais tous les jeunes ne prennent pas de
drogue non bien sûr je dois dire que
nous avons beaucoup d'étudiants qui
viennent mais là aussi c'est pour des
voyages organisés
et ses voyages organisés ce n'est pas
vraiment le genre de claudine
heureusement les paysages lui plaisent
ya pas beaucoup de maisons a pas
beaucoup d'habitants c'est bien j'aime
bien
ça me fait plus penser à
l'origine la baroudeuse a une manie elle
cueille des feuilles surtout celles qui
ont un symbole châtre a gardé si ça fait
que ce religieuse à il faut que
j'attrape une feuille
célèbre du bouddha pas
si vous perdez claudine vous êtes sûr de
la retrouver sous un arbre
mais à lui souvent là lapointe et plus
longuement force et
ça fait un cadeau aux gens qu'ils
succession suis loin de vous dise une
fois je ne l'avais rapportant je fais
cadeau à tous les copains et copines
c'est est ravi et au niveau de
l'ambiance générale ainsi des contracts
il
faut prendre
si je crois
[Rires]
comme la suisse le bouton est réputé
pour la pureté de sa nature au programme
du jour randonnée à 3000 m d'altitude
claude et monique sont en terrain connu
il ne voyage que dans les pays montagne
claudine elle a décidé de se laisser
porter
quant à robert il porte un maillot qui
ne se fondra pas dans le décor quelques
moines qui sont les gardiens du temple
et puis tout au sommet de la falaise dao
ce sont des ermitages ou ville de tiznit
mais qui sont en retraite
donc moi je pars en jogging si vous
permettez et c'est parti
attention et on y va
notre éclaireur est un ancien
photographe il a séjourné près de
soixante fois au bhoutan ce qu'il aime
c'est les ruptures de rythme on vit en
france dans un monde qui est plus se
tourmenter tout et stresse tout est
actif en cours souvent les relations
sont parfois plus difficiles de nombreux
facteurs font que on est content ici de
retrouver effectivement cette pureté 7,7
choses comme ça très équilibré très
agréable
les esprits contemplatif sont à la
traîne pour michel une croyante cette
ascension à quelque chose de spirituel
rentrer dans la semaine sainte oui j'ai
l'impression que ce parcours pour moi
catholique pour aller jusqu'à pâques
c'est super oui que je suis presque
mieux à marcher fait dans une église
pour admirer la nature pour remercier
de toutes ces beautés
au monastère nous voulons visiter le
temple mais problème les bhoutanais le
protège des caméras les touristes ont dû
se délester
non seulement de leurs chaussures ce qui
est normal mais aussi de leur appareil
photo et de leurs téléphones portables
affaires sensibles mais resca liés au
barrage
quant à nous nous sommes unis
d'autorisations spéciales mais une
agitation bureaucratique s'empare de
notre guide bhoutanais et de l'armée qui
gardent le site
alors comme ça tout le monde peut venir
filmer le temple maintenant on a un
permis spécial qu'une télévision veuille
entrer dans le temple est une affaire
d'état
appelle le préfet sans son portable
et on attend toujours la permission
elle va venir ça négocie encore
signé ce papier
il ya un côté un peu protectionnistes un
peu peur de deux finalement de ces
invasions touristique un petit peu puis
tout ce que j'ai ce qui arrive de
l'occident donc oui c'est vrai quel
point ils ont tendance un peu à se
protéger voire se surprotéger
le préfet donne finalement son accord
affaire classée
nous pénétrons ce sanctuaire qu'aucune
télévision d'un film et il est dédié au
père du bouddhisme au bhoutan venus
d'inde il s'est réfugié ici même après
un voyage étonnant à gauche vous avez
donc goût rimpoché le fameux maître
indien qui est arrivé ici on dit au
viiie siècle sur le dos d'un tigres
volants
à
des statues imposante
et des admirateurs mutique
[Musique]
le résultat quand on arrive aux sommes
effectivement cei
l'extraordinaire
tellement vanté les merveilles du buteur
effectivement c'est un rêve qui se
réalise
mais ils n'ont pas le temps de méditer
sur leur bonne fortune
dans la vallée il doit visiter cette
ferme du 16e siècle où le temps et reste
figé
ce qu'ils ne savent pas c'est que l'
agence bhoutanaise qui organisent leur
voyage a fait venir un invité surprise
personne n'a été prévenu
c'est un grand prêtre du bouddhisme un
lama qui nous reçoit
j'aurais d'abord introduire le lama qui
est à ma gauche et qui est kempo ponceau
tashi s'éteindre cette invitation n'est
pas obligatoire mais personne n'ose la
décliner une question
ou là vous la ramenez plus
non seulement cela m'a veut les voir
mais il veut aussi les entendre c'est un
hamac curieuse à votre avis pourquoi
aujourd'hui
en occident en europe ou aux états unis
pourquoi les légions les options ou
deviennent bouddhiste
il n'y a pas une pratique
obligatoire
il n'y a pas de rythme et
bien moi j'ai l'impression qu'en
occident le bouddhisme est en train de
devenir une sorte de mode mais il peut y
avoir aussi un petit peu plus élevé un
abord philosophique la philosophie
bouddhiste peut vous toucher sans qu on
ait envie de s'engager dans la religion
bouddhiste du cosmos après le débat
activités méditation
elle permettrait d'accéder
temporairement à ce fameux bonheur
si les bhoutanais intègre aussi
naturellement un cours de bouddhisme
dans un programme de vacances c'est
parce que c'est leur religion d'état
quant à nos français ils sont plutôt mon
public
[Musique]
le lendemain exercice pratique à
l'initiative des français cette fois ils
ont acheté ces drapeaux de prière que
les bouddhistes place au vent
pour michel nous et ses tissus est un
acte de foi
de foi chrétienne
c'est la tradition dans ce pays moi je
me prête donc
pour nous c'est pâques
quels sont les messages que vous envoyez
au monde un message de paix d'abord
cette tradition bouddhiste qui intéresse
en aux touristes elle s'exprimait avant
tout dans les festivals
celui de parrot est un événement annuel
pour des milliers de bhoutanais et
quelques chasseurs d'image
rendez vous religieux et non pas
folklorique
dieuze et démons s'affrontent lens est
dense
[Musique]
sur la façade du monastère une immense
bannière a été déployée
au son lancinant des prières les fidèles
l'admirent et la touche car elle
apporterait le bonheur encore lui
tous sont en tenue traditionnelle et ce
n'est pas seulement pour l'occasion les
bhoutanais doivent la porter tous les
jours à l'école au travail et pour les
rendez vous importants
si on s'asseyait sur la base sur les
pierres sur un petit muret on va se
reposer 5 minutes son auberge va
présenter cet étudiant à ces touristes
qui pose beaucoup de questions sur la
jeunesse bhoutanaise
un autre français s'est jointe à nous il
fait partie d'un groupe de trekkeurs
l'étudiant sa belle chimie il est plutôt
patriotes comme tous les jeunes
bhoutanais que nous avons rencontrés tu
veux travailler au bhoutan ou à
l'étranger
je me dois de travailler pour mon pays
mais j'ai aussi besoin de découvrir le
monde extérieur
pourquoi tu dis je me dois parce que
c'est une question de conscience et
sinon tu te sens heureux tu ressens ce
bonheur national
ben oui trop
comment est ce que je peux exprimer ça
d'abord je suis heureux d'être avec vous
tous en ce moment et puis au bouton on
pense que c'est à chacun de se fixer un
niveau de satisfaction
savoir à partir de quel niveau je peux
me sentir heureux c'est ça la clé
maturité inattendu chez un jeune homme
de 25 ans
les françaises après si
il
[Applaudissements]
veut garder les traditions
tout en voulant quand même allez voyager
mais il veut rester quand même
son but en
promesses de courrier pour une amitié
naissante
nous nous repasserons voir chimie
pourquoi les bhoutanais sont ils devenus
des experts du bonheur parce qu'ils en
ont fait un indice quantifiables comme
le produit national brut d'où ce nom
bonheur national brut le bnb un concept
unique au monde qui régit toute la
politique au bhoutan
celui qui le calcul travail dans ce
vaste chalet qui respire la quiétude
car maura et philosophe il a été chargé
de fabriquer la recette du bonheur
[Musique]
car maura a sélectionné 72 ingrédients
qui l'a testé auprès des habitants par
exemple l'utilisation du temps
la connaissance de la nature
la confiance dans les institutions
le niveau de vie et le bien-être
psychologique
il distingue les émotions positives
comme la compassion la sérénité la
générosité des émotions négatives
face c'est la frustration l'égoïsme et
la jalousie nous les mesures ont quel
est le pourcentage de gens qui
ressentent fréquemment des émotions
négatives
par exemple vous pouvez voir la
distribution des émotions négatives
district par district et c'est dans la
capitale que le niveau est le plus élevé
car maura va transformer toutes ces
données en un chiffre après d'obscurs
opération
'l'indice du bnb est égal à 0 64 mon
score paraît-il le gouvernement va
chercher à l'augmenter
si on le compare à bien d'autres pays
malgré le fait que nos revenus
financiers soient bas le peuple
bhoutanais est un peuple très heureux
la raison c'est que les revenus
financiers ne sont pas la clé du
bien-être
pour les autorités bhoutanaise le bnb
est même plus important que le pnb
pratique quand on est un pays peu
développés malin aussi car l'idée est
une belle vitrine pour les occidentaux
alors ça devient compliqué nous
soumettons la recette à nos français
d'abord scepticisme
mais très vite il se projette
surtout philippe et geneviève qui ne
sont pas retraités mais cadre
personnel
que j'ai beaucoup de
soin personnel
même s'il ya des gens qui sont 35 heures
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'y sont pas allés voir pas du tout il
ya très peu de personnes qui ont une vie
personnelle intense profonde qui
prennent le temps de bien de faire un
peu ce que moi j'appelle de
l'introspection c'est à dire se situer
par rapport aux autres on est dans une
situation qu'on sort mais on veut avoir
plus que le voisin on est très
individualiste donc on a oublié
certaines valeurs fondamentales en mon
sens
cette politique du bonheur qui fait
s'interroger les occidentaux qui l'a
décidé la famille royale elle-même
nous allons l'approché cette fois sans
nos touristes à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie féerique
le bhoutan couronne son cinquième roi
à deux pas du tapis rouge robert fait
partie des invités
le photographe est célèbre au bhoutan
il nous tient la chronique mondaine
locale
agissez ring
tu étais la seconde est plus que
quatrième roi du bhoutan
voilà donc le roi
jigme et on tchouk à 28 ans c'est le roi
le plus jeune du monde comme sa
démocratie les bhoutanais ont voté pour
la première fois l'an dernier
il tient à saluer tous ses invités
et lorsqu'il reconnaît robert il
s'approche
il faut que je vous dise bonjour
comment allez vous
le jeune roi et le photographe se
connaissent depuis 15 ans
à
il est comme ça c'est dur elle je pense
que là une espèce de bonté naturelle en
été et qu'il ait manifesté qui se sent
monter les banques c'est un homme
charmant port
est tellement important pour vous de sa
levée tout le monde
c'est très important
notre peuple est important chaque
individu compte c'est ça le bonheur
national brut
l'individu compte
je suis très heureux que vous soyez ici
merci beaucoup le bonheur pour tous
c'est le visage que le bouton va offrir
au monde mais nous allons le voir il y à
une ombre au tableau
ce soir l' agence de voyages organise
une discussion à bâtons rompus sur la
politique bhoutanaise le secrétaire
d'état à l'intérieur s'est déplacé sans
doute motivée par la présence de notre
caméra
claudine pose d'abord une question
féministe sur l'omniprésence des hommes
dans les institutions le secrétaire
d'état confirme et claude enchaîne
[Rires]
chez moi aussi
exposé sympathique mais qui fait
l'impasse sur une question à la fin des
années 80 le bhoutan expulsés par la
force pas moins de 100 milles népalais
sous couvert de protéger l'identité
bhoutanaise
ils sont dans des camps de réfugiés au
népal
sujet tabou bien qu'il s'en défende
ne pensez pas que c'est un problème pour
l'image du bhoutan
non je ne pense pas que ça nous affecte
c'est juste une histoire d'immigration
mais ce n'est pas une question que vous
abordez avec les touristes n'ai rien à
cacher pourquoi voulez vous qu'on cache
quelque chose
pendant notre séjour avec les touristes
nous n'entendrons pas parler d expulser
népalais
avant de repartir nous avions promis de
passer voir chimie notre étudiant du
festival à l'université il veut nous
montrer comment les bhoutanais affronte
la mondialisation
internet est une révolution
le roi ne l'a autorisé qu il y a dix ans
mais pour ces étudiants pas d'ouverture
sans piqûre de rappel
ce prof en scène une matière dont nous
n'aurions jamais soupçonné l'existence
commerce et éthique bouddhiste
on y entend des prières les mantras et
des phrases qui désarmerait nos cadres
commerciaux
il est possible pour un homme d'affaires
de faire du profit en plein accord avec
la religion bouddhiste
de cette manière nous pouvons progresser
et atteindre le stade de l'éveil le
nirvana qui est notre but ultime
plus étonnant encore une activité que
timmy va nous montrer et qui n'existe
nulle part ailleurs qu'au bhoutan
là c'est la seule de développement
personnel c'est ici que les étudiants
développent leur personnalité s'expose
au monde extérieur il y à une télévision
s'exposer au monde cet allumé la télé
elle n'est autorisé que depuis 1999
autant dire hier
ils regardent ce film d'action grand
public comme un documentaire sur les
coutumes américaine
quand vous regardez un film américain
qu'est ce que vous apprenez
dans les films américains les histoires
sont très complexes
ça nous donne une pensée plus forte
vous vous souvenez de la première fois
que vous avez vus à la télé oui c'était
incroyable
on n'avait jamais rien vu de tel voir
ces gens qui bougeait dans une petite
boîte
le bouton peut-il entre ouvrir sa porte
à la culture occidentale sans se faire
happer
ce petit pays balance entre deux époques
et ce qu'ils aiment comme robert huth un
peu peur de le voir changer
[Musique]
est ce que le bouton dans vingt ans dans
trente ans aura pu préserver comme on
l'a vu cette espèce de saveurs qui fait
sa nature même et son identité je sais
pas
le voyage n'a pas déçu nos touristes il
était presque acquis d'avancé
les gens qui viennent important levier
pour chercher quelque chose ou mais
parce qu'ils sont en quête aussi quelque
chose ne confirme pas au bhoutan par
hasard
ce bonheur national il le voit comme une
belle invention
[Musique]
comme disent les sages le bonheur n'est
pas au bout du chemin
le bonheur c'est le chemin
[Musique]